we're told that imran is two years older
than dia dia is two how old is imran so
i encourage you to pause this video and
try to think about this yourself how old
is imran given the information here
so let's use some letters to represent
imran and dia's age let's say that i
is equal to imran's age
imran's age and let's say that d is
equal to dia's age d is equal to
diaz
diaz age
so given that what does this first
sentence tell us
it says that imran's age imran is two
years older than dia so imran
imran's age is going to be equal to
dia's age is going to be equal to dia's
age
plus two
plus two that's what this first sentence
tells us imran's age is dia's age plus
two imran is two years older than dia
another way you could think about it if
we were to imagine their ages on a
number line right over here
so if this is 0
and then this is dia's age right over
here this is d is age let me do in that
same color
this is dia's age right over here if you
were to add two to these age so if you
were to go two more
if you were to go two more
so plus two you would get two imran's
age
you would get to imran's age so that's
what this first sentence tells us
then they tell us that dia is 2. so
that's like saying that
d which we're using to represent d is h
that's going to be equal to 2. so this
thing is equal to two this thing right
over here is equal to two so we can
rewrite this as
imran's age is equal to d as age which
we now to be know to be two
plus two
plus two so what's two plus two well you
know that that's going to be four
so imran's age
is going to be equal to four if this is
two right over here and then you were to
go up two more you're going to get to
four imran's age is four
let's try one more of these
so here we we're told that the giraffe
at the zoo is three times taller than
shantanu
shantanu is six feet tall how tall is
the giraffe so once again i encourage
you to pause this video and try to think
about it on your own
let's use this do the same idea let's
use some letters to represent the
different the different heights so g for
giraffe and s for chantinew so they say
the giraffe the and i'll use g for the
height of the giraffe
the height of the giraffe is three times
taller
is three times taller not three more
feet three times taller than chantinews
height so we could say that the
giraffe's height is equal to three
times
three times chantinew's height
three times shanthanu's height so just
let's be clear with it the g
represents the height of the giraffe s
represents the height of shanthanu so
another way of thinking about it let me
see if i can draw a giraffe reasonably
here
so
if this is the giraffe actually i'm not
this isn't a bad job at drawing a
giraffe so this is the giraffe right
over here
they're saying that if you take shot
news height times three you get to the
giraffe's height so let me make actually
giraffe might have longer legs than that
so this is g the height of the giraffe
is g
and chanting is height so let's say this
is chanting his height if i multiply
that by three i get the giraffe's height
so let me divide let me see one two
so
shanthanu might look something like
this
and if you took three times his height
so this is one time his height two times
his height three times his height you
would get to the height of the giraffe
so that's what this first sentence tells
us
shantanu is six feet tall so they tell
us that this height right over here this
height right over here is six feet or
another way of saying it is s is equal
to six feet how tall is the giraffe well
once again s is equal to six feet so the
giraffe's height
is equal to
three
times jonathan's height which we now
know to be six feet so three
times
six feet
so in feet
the giraffe's height is three times six
well we know that three times six is 18.
giraffe's height is and we're dealing
with feet so the giraffe height is 18
feet and you see that right over here
six feet
plus another six feet
or six feet times three is going to get
you
is going to get you to
18 feet